now the stuff we teach here and have for
almost 30 years is proven it's no longer
an opinion it's not a theory I don't
agree with Dave Ramsey's advice which
would make you wrong and I know you're
writing a blog from your mother's
basement you're looking for clickbait
using my name I understand that but
you're wrong and it's always humorous to
me to see people who are broke on
Twitter ragging on the advice that I
give or a broke 26 year old journalism
student deeply in student loan debt
writing an article about me that's
humorous because it's stupid here's the
thing here's the advice that we give you
if you do these five things from the
Bible and from your grandmother they're
called common sense you will win with
money 100% of the time now I don't know
exactly how long it will take you and I
don't know what win with money will mean
because I cannot predict your income and
I cannot predict the tragedy that you
will have to overcome but subject to
your income to tragedy ratio to the
extent you do these five things you will
win with money you will become wealthy
in North America if you will do these
five things over and over again number
one you need to have a written plan a
budget jesus said don't build a tower
without first counting the cost lest you
get halfway up and you're unable to
finish and all who see you begin to mock
you and say this man began to build no
one would begin to build and was unable
to finish no one accidentally wins at
anything and you're not the exception
I don't like Dave Ramsey's advice I
don't give a crap you're wrong you have
to do a written gameplan with money are
you gonna
Lu's second thing is you got to get out
of that your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and when
you spend your whole freakin life giving
your money to banks who fill up the
skyline and have furniture nicer than
yours that makes you stupid get out of
debt when you don't have any payments
you know what you've got money do I care
if you get out of that yes I want you to
win I want you to have a great life but
do I care if you agree with me no I
don't care if you agree with me if you
don't agree with me about this money
stuff you're what's known as wrong I've
been doing this longer than most of my
critics they were peeing in their diaper
while I was doing this stuff they're
wrong live on less than you make number
three in the house of the wiser stars
stores of choice food and oil but a
foolish man delivers all devours all
that he has if you spend everything you
make you're a fool well Dave you don't
know about my situation in America today
wages are stagnant so why are they
stagnant at your house you know where
wages are stagnant on people who are
stagnant you're only stagnant gotten
stagnant wages if you decide to stay
there and keep getting those wages this
is not Russia
you can quit I don't like how much
Walmart pays I don't like how much
McDonald's pay so don't work they're
stupid go to work for somebody else
I don't like out my company treats me so
leave go be somebody there's no reason
that you have to be stuck somewhere
because some liberal journalist said you
were stuck you're not stuck you're
stagnant don't be stagnant you know what
stagnant pond water does it gross scum
on top you don't want to be stagnant you
get scummy you need to go be somebody
you need to leave the cave kill
something and drag it on you need to
decide that my life is not
if the way it is and so I am going to
control the controllables I am going to
change some things because guess what
nobody in Washington is going to fix
your life Santa Claus doesn't live there
baby have you noticed that the Democrats
and the Republicans neither one could
freaking ad have you ever had any of
them send you money no they are not
going to fix your freaking life you are
gonna fix your life you're gonna get on
a plane you're gonna get out of debt
you're gonna live on less than you make
and then you're gonna save some money
you know how rich people get rich they
save money Wow I don't know if I agree
with Dave Ramsey's investment
assumptions I don't give a crap if you
agree with my investment assumptions you
know what my investment assumption is my
assumption is you're gonna be broke
until you save money that's my
assumption you need to get up off your
assumption and go do something you need
to get up off your assumption and start
investing some money 100 percent of the
people that don't save money don't have
any wow how's that for insight doesn't
take a freaking rocket scientist to
figure this out you know what the
problem on your investments are the
problem with your investments is not
your rate of return it's not your
expense ratio it's not no load versus
load it's not your nerdy twisted up
toxic but opinion about some investment
your problem with your investments is
you don't have any that's the problem
with your investments 100 percent of the
people that build wealth save money on
purpose a lot some people do it poorly
in a stupid money market accounting make
no money on their money others do it
wisely in mutual funds that outperform
the S&P or real estate that they pay
cash for that outperforms the S P others
are just passive and do the S P and they
all write books about it and all have a
freaking opinion and make money off of
you while you're stagnant that's stupid
don't be stagnant invest money save
money you know how you're gonna do that
you're gonna be on a plan you're gonna
get off out of that you're gonna live on
less than you make and voila there is
money in the budget it's called margin
baby and now you got the money to be
rich you got to act like rich people and
that's not gonna spend a bunch of money
more on
cuz rich people don't go spend a bunch
of money I'm gonna go buy a Ferrari I'm
acting like rich people no you're acting
like a [ __ ]
that's not Ferraris aren't rich people
that's the ultra-rich you don't buy a
Ferrari if you're a millionaire that's a
seven I mean it's crazy you people yeah
I'm gonna act rich I'm gonna rip people
off that's just a liberal nonsense rich
people don't rip people off they can get
rich by ripping people off that's just
stupid
don't be stupid it makes you look bad
don't do that if you'll get out of debt
and you don't invest and you live on
less than you make and you have a plan
then you can do the last one it's the
most fun you'll ever have with money you
could be outrageously generous randomly
generous lavishly generous but broke
people can't do that because they sit
around and discuss their investment
philosophies and while they invest
nothing there's like people smoking weed
discussing the meaning of life they
ain't getting nothing done you need to
get up off your assumptions and go do
something it's your turn
[Music]